y justamente parte de lo que está
sucediendo es no sólo una visita de
pelosi fue lo que disparó esta tensión
entre pekín y eeuu sino que este propio
acuerdo había sido uno de los
disparadores más analizados por pekín
para para con todo lo que es esta crisis
que estamos viviendo el acuerdo es un
acuerdo marco que se va a dar entre
naturalmente eeuu y taiwán y lo que
busca es fomentar el comercio entre las
dos naciones o entre las dos de los dos
enclaves entre un país y una nación en
ciernes por así decir en definitiva lo
que busca también es materializar un
suministro importantísimo que tiene está
igual en cuanto al microprocesadores
para el resto de la cadena mundial se
podría llegar realmente a un escenario
de enfrentamiento directo entre china y
taiwán de materializarse este acuerdo
en definitiva me parece que no
china pekín por así decir le tiene miedo
algo que está por fuera de lo que serían
los países y las naciones que es el
mercado si de alguna forma entra en
guerra e invade la isla y tiene algún
tipo de acción sobre taipei va a empezar
una guerra y una guerra hoy a china no
le conviene se le van a cerrar todos los
mercados a nivel mundial las cadenas de
suministro fundamentalmente de las
cadenas bancarias no creo que china
pekín esté pensando en esto en este
momento para ellos es muy importante el
crecimiento económico todavía sin
embargo la dialéctica es de escalada de
tensión podría estar buscando china
también con esto un acuerdo aparte del
de taiwán con eeuu
en la norma general de china en cuanto a
sus expresiones hacia lo que sería la
población interna y fundamentalmente
para el periodismo y lo que sería su
difusión en general es de una escalada
demasiado demasiado grande y
grandilocuente él se ha dado a sí en
casi todo fundamentalmente hay que
estudiarlo en los procesos que se dieron
con el tema del hobbit acá lo mismo los
anuncios fueron enormemente grandes no
digo que no hayan sido algunas
situaciones complejas frente a taiwán
pero tampoco no fue aquello de que va a
correr sangre etcétera etcétera y eeuu
tampoco
dio un paso atrás y ahora tenemos una
segunda delegación y que queda claro que
no son los demócratas y son demócratas
sensibles publicando lo que están
visitando la isla y que eeuu continúa
con su política acá es claro de que si
china quiere que estados unidos
reconozca que hay una sola china el
poder ejecutivo la puede reconocer pero
el poder legislativo tiene su por su
propia gente
carlos veríssimo starace muchas gracias
por atendernos en france 24